ورقه سياسيه واقتصاديه تستخدمها اسرائيل
دائما لابتزاز السلطه الفلسطينيه دون اي
رادع اموال المقاصه اهم ادوات حكومه رام
الله لفرض سلطتها على الضفه الغربيه لكنها
بدات تتاكل على غرار الجانب السياسي
والامني فما قصه الشريان المالي لالاف
الموظفين
الفلسطينيين ولماذا تتحكم به
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل
ثمه شائعه تقول ان اموال المقاصه هي تمويل
اسرائيلي لحكومه السلطه الوطنيه لكن هذا
خطا بل هي ببساطه اموال لتجار فلسطينيين
تجمع من الضرائب المفروضه على السلع
المستورده الى الجانب الفلسطيني سواء من
داخل اسرائيل او من المعابر الحدوديه
الاسرائيليه البريه والبحريه والجويه ووفق
بروتوكول باريس الاقتصادي الموقع عام
1994 بين اسرائيل والسلطه تتولى وزاره
الماليه الاسرائيليه جبايه اموال المقاصه
على المعابر وتحصل على 3% منها متوسط هذه
الاموال يقدر باكثر من
255 مليون دولار شهريه ولكن ما كان يصل
الجانب الفلسطيني قبل الحرب على غزه يبلغ
203 ملايين دولار وتقتطع اسرائيل اكثر من
40 مليون دولار بحجه تسديد ديون السلطه
لشركات الكهرباء والماء او لاسباب اخرى
وتشترط اسرائيل الحصول على مبلغ مساو لما
تقدمه السلطه للاسرى في سجون الاحتلال وهو
ما يتجاوز 16 مليون دولار شهريا وبعد حساب
الاقتطاعات كلها تشكل اموال المقاصه
65% من مجمل دخل الحكومه الفلسطينيه ويعني
هذا ان اي خلل باستلامها يحرم الموظفين من
اجورهم ويحد من قدره السلطه على الايفاء
بالتزاماتها الماليه تجاه مؤسساتها
الحكوميه ومنذ توقيع اتفاقيه اوسلو قبل 30
عاما تلاعبت اسرائيل بتسليم هذه الاموال
اث عش مره لضغط على الفلسطينيين وتحقيق
اهداف سياسيه اخر تلك المرات كانت في
نوفمبر تشرين الثاني
2023 بعد شهر من عمليه الاقصى اذ اقتصت 73
مليون دولار من اموال المقاصه بحجه انها
المخصصات الشهريه لقطاع غزه فرفضت السلطه
تسلم المبلغ منقوصا ما عمق ازمتها الماليه
اكثر الجديد في هذه المره ان اسرائيل لم
تتلاعب بالاموال بهدف التهديد وحسب بل
اقرت اليه جديده لتسليم الاموال تنسف بنود
بروتوكول باريس تنص الاليه على تسليم
الاموال لطرف ثالث هو دوله النرويج على ان
تحول النرويج الاموال للسلطه بشروط كثيره
تضمن لاسرائيل ان تنفقها السلطه على اشياء
محدده ولا يذهب منها فلس واحد لغزه بحسب
مصادر اسرائيليه هذه الاليه عد عن كونها
تقلص سياده السلطه الوطنيه التي تتاكل
اصلا فانها تعد شرعان دوليه للاقتطاع
الاسرائيليه من تلك الاموال ترسخ رؤيه
وزراء نتنياهو باحتجاز اموال غزه وفق ما
يرى الكاتب المختص بالشان الاسرائيلي محمد
ابو علان المحدد الاول والاخير لتمرير هذه
الاليه او تعطيلها هو السلطه الفلسطينيه
وهذا ما سيظهر في موقفها النهائي من
استلام الاموال او رفض الاليه الجديده من
اصلها